as a young girl growing up in the
Philippines no one could have guessed
what life would have in store for lloyda
Lewis not even Lewis herself she's now a
celebrated philanthropist who shattered
glass ceilings in the legal world and
became the CEO of a billion dollar
company all while dealing with
devastating laws it's a journey detailed
in her new book why should guys have all
the fun
so is this the pink room we call it the
Picasso the Picasso the Picasso is his
favorite because he won it at an auction
loyda Lewis's art collection was her
husband's pride and joy won the late
Reginald Lewis acquired much like
everything else the tenacity of Mr Lewis
five years he went and visited Roman
virgin's video and four times she said
no she knew he will not stop many of his
keepsakes are now enshrined so what's in
here
says that he loved Monte Cristo cigar
reminders of their 24-year marriage
three decades after his death I'm
curious to know what if you hadn't met
Reginald Lewis where you might be today
well probably a senator or even a
concert pianist
one thing's for certain she was no
Trophy Wife even for the first black
American to build a billion dollar
business
what is this from this is the Blue Room
which is really a room for memorabilia
the seemingly demure Widow has candidly
spilled the tea and why should guys have
all the fun after 30 years I said I
think especially women should know that
we are capable we are not men but we are
capable anything he can do we can do not
better but differently it nods to her
husband's Memoir why should white guys
have all the fun a book she inspired
after pinning her own books first if it
sounds like she's a bit of an
overachiever thank her parents she
graduated the top of her law school
class in the Philippines acing her bar
exam she was gifted a trip around the
world from her dad but fell in love with
New York City while visiting her sister
and after finding a job found her role
as a Matchmaker who thinks of
introducing their sister to their boss
of course every and for me it's very
natural you know my stuff's not natural
no but my sister has always been uh
prettier than I am and my boss was fast
they were going out on the date that
weekend so for Friday he asked me loyda
why don't I fix a double date you know
I've never been on the blind date so
that was a new adventure I said sure six
months later she proposed to that said
date then you kind of reneged on the
proposal yes yes why
being married to an American living in
the United States means I will leave my
country I will live my ambition I will
leave my parents he was broken-hearted
what changed your mind I was so so sad
having graduated from college of law
University of the Philippines I was with
the best of the best and you know I knew
that Reginald Lewis is different from
all of them he was masterful by 1987 the
corporate attorney turned his sights to
business and leveraged a buyout of an
International Food Company worth 985
million dollars he renamed it TLC
Beatrice International Holdings Inc
later that year it nearly doubled its
Revenue becoming the first black owned
company to have more than a billion
dollars in annual sales he became a
billionaire before the age of 50. I
would say that it was his
inner desire
prove
white people wrong
that a black man can reach the height
that any white man can do while he ran
the world she practiced immigration law
all the while raising two daughters but
in 1992 Reginald Lewis was diagnosed
with terminal brain cancer I was out of
sort I was totally discombobulated
anytime I hear about the song or I just
remember him I would just cry about and
then after six months around December I
started to think now what do I have here
my two girls I will be mother and father
to them so that's one number two the
book it had to be finished and then the
third one is the company a company on
the edge of bankruptcy during the 1993
recession and after a year-long search
no successor so loyda took the reins I'm
sure there were detractors there were
people who said what is she thinking she
can do taking over this business yes no
I didn't listen besides I came from a
very entrepreneurial family and then 24
years being married to Reginald Lewis I
was an active listener and I'm a lawyer
I'm not intimidated by documents I never
heard any negative word and from my
board of directors if they didn't want
me I can dismiss them because we own 51
you're like I got all the cards yes
exactly she weighs 2.2 billion dollars
in Revenue before selling the company
these days Lewis is building a legacy a
Baltimore Museum that bears her
husband's name this museum is a
celebration of excellence and it's a
celebration
of a family
who epitomizes what Excellence looks
like Maryland governor Wes Moore
believes it will inspire the Next
Generation not just in business but the
Partnerships that build lives she's
found a way of being able to look at
everything that life gives her as not an
an obstacle but an opportunity at 81
loyda Lewis remains full of life yet
she's still a woman very much in love
it's hard
I'm sorry no yeah it's hard
even now 30 years later 30 years later
yeah I still have my my wedding ring
not available
he could have done so many more things
yes he was he was special
wow and she still believes there's more
that she needs to do to increase
people's knowledge of who this man was
and what he did if you were called TLC
Beatrice was the maker of equal and
equal oh yeah like change the landscape
of artificial sweeteners from Sweet and
Low then there it was equal and then
Splenda and ice cream and all sorts of
other things he really put in on the map
I feel like I almost learned something
about him just by seeing the woman he
spent his life with the confidence you
know there were doubters well I don't
know I didn't listen to them right she's
a force she is a force